Tyler bass missed the kick that could
have saved the Bill's season so you
would assume Bill's Mafia would go after
him with everything they had I mean he
deactivated his social media in
preparation for the hatred but bills
Nation did the most bills thing ever
they donated more than $7,000 to his
charity 10 lives Club I also need to add
if you were watching the game and know
anything about football you know the
outcome of the game wasn't solely
because of bass's Mis kick clearly
Bill's Mafia knows football but this
selfless act wasn't a one-time deal for
Bill's fans they donated almost half a
million dollarss to Andy and Jordan
Dalton's found Foundation they donated
$4 million to Demar Hamlin's toy drive
they donated to TU a tonga vioa
Foundation post concussion and more
Bill's Mafia deserves all the flowers